oh
hello there i didn't know you'd be there
well
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report direct message today
is july 6th 2021 do me a favor
subscribe to our channel tap that
notification bell
maybe you never know our videos will
show up in your youtube feed
very possibly they won't but it's worth
a shot isn't it all right guys we're
going to get right to it today we got
four stories for you first off
uh you know this joe biden guy he's the
old guy who putters around and
uh holds note cards when he's talking
often is confused doesn't know what he's
saying
well now people are kind of picking up
on that and a new poll
shows that more than 50 percent of
people don't think he's in charge which
is interesting because it's a
question that i asked uh president trump
about a week and a half ago who's
really in charge and then trump actually
went to a rally a couple days ago and
then he asked the audience
the audience didn't know either we'll
show you that we'll show you the poll uh
the second story
critical race theory uh which many would
just say is an idea
if you're watching the blue and on
conspiracy channel over there on msnbc
there's this
um notion out there that critical race
theory
sort of really doesn't exist or it's not
really in schools and yet at the same
time it must be taught and it is their
new religion it's very very confusing
uh well it is infecting everything and
that's why i keep saying to you guys
we must build new things that by the way
is exactly what i'm doing of course with
locals.com
but the old things are going to crumble
and speaking of old things the newest
thing that has been now basically wholly
infected by critical race theory and
we'll get into the details
uh is the uh teachers union which
basically is just they're going all in
there they are just
we will bring racism to your children in
the name of anti-racism so we'll
dive deep on that and then uh men
in women's prisons it's the new hottest
trend
and it's happening here in california
and you may remember because we played
the video
during the election joe biden said that
it won't be up to uh you it won't be up
to the
uh the prison basically to decide who is
going to go into what prison meaning if
you're a man
it won't be up to them to decide it'll
be up to you how you identify that'll be
whether you're going to a male prison or
a woman's prison well it's happening
here
in california and you're not going to
believe this guys
there are rapes there are murders and
other violent attacks on women
by biological men bananas right and then
finally speaking of bananas
new york once the greatest city in the
world
a place that i grew up that my
grandparents lived in my
great-grandparents lived in at times
i talked about this in my book in the
early 1900s there were dozens probably
around 50 people in my family lived in
new york city and
in all the boroughs there we now have
one cousin
left well i'm fairly certain doesn't
talk to me because of trump arrangement
syndrome but we have one
family member left in new york city and
why because crime is completely out of
control
and it looks like they will have a new
progressive d.a
and he's going to basically
decriminalize everything
trespassing looting a whole bunch of
stuff and basically turn whatever
decency is left in new york city and
it's hard to know what's left they're
going to try to turn it into san
francisco
and we've got videotape of san francisco
and trust me
it's nuts all right let's start off with
uh with this joe biden guy because it's
becoming fairly obvious
that he is not in charge i mean i think
everyone sort of sees it at this point
he often when he gives these press
conferences where he has
uh i'm going to choose you and you're
going to do this
he always has his notes and he
everything's pre-packaged and he's
always reading from a prompter but even
despite all that he is struggling
to make coherent sentences often gets
completely
sort of sidetracked and badly and just
sort of stares into oblivion and
everything else
the scandal as i've been saying is the
non-scandal the scandal is not that
there's something wrong with joe biden
that that is a scandal
of some sort i would say right like it's
it's a problem
would you say it's a problem that you
know the guy that we're supposed to
believe is
is the leader of the free world
obviously has cognitive problems yeah
okay that's a scandal
but i would say the bigger scandal is
the non-scandal the bigger scandal is
the fact that corporate press
mainstream media cable news you know all
the respectable blue check journalists
that everyone's pretending they don't
see this so the scandal is actually the
non-scandal the scandal's the fact that
we're not really talking about the
scandal uh but the average person is
picking up on it
so there was a new poll by trafalgar
group
and we've got some info here from the
daily wire a new poll released on monday
found the majority of americans believe
that others
are really running the show in president
joe biden's administration
and not biden himself 56.5
of american voters do not believe that
president biden is fully executing the
duties of his office
while 36.4 believe he's directing all
policy
and agenda so that that's a pretty
interesting poll right over half of the
people
in america basically are saying they
don't think joe biden is in charge now
this is the same exact question
that i asked donald trump as i said
about 10 days ago and he
sort of said he didn't know you know is
it the obama machine the hillary machine
i don't know who it is i don't know i'd
love to hear your thoughts
on who you think it is i think it is
something like whatever is left
of the clinton machine coupled with the
obama machine which
is directly connected to all the blm
stuff and the antifa stuff like it's
just some really weird
radical left thing but like who's really
funding it who's really in charge
but the simple point here is that i i
just don't know how you could
be a thinking person and believe that
joe biden is in charge he often during
his
uh ramblingly incoherent press
conferences
he'll often say oh i better stop now or
i'm going to get in trouble i mean you
can find many videos of this
i'm going to get in trouble they're not
going to be happy about this who is he
talking about
like really who is he talking about now
i get it he could be like
being a little bit kitschy right it's a
little bit like oh i've said too much
i'm going to get in trouble
and he just means it as a joke but he
repeatedly keeps saying it and it's
usually not done in a joking manner it's
like oh i just said that i'm going to
get in trouble
and then on top of everything else they
are giving him note cards
imagine if donald trump had been walking
around for four years with note cards
during those insanely
combative press conferences and by the
way i don't mind
insanely combative press conferences
because that's sort of what's supposed
to happen right you're supposed to have
journalists
who are non-partisan asking difficult
questions of elected leaders that's a
beautiful thing now what we have is
basically
a bunch of journalists asking joe biden
about how many scoops of ice cream he
had
and of course when donald trump had two
scoops of ice cream it was a big problem
joe biden can have as many
scoops of ice cream as he wants and i
sense over the next couple years there's
going to be a lot more soft food in his
future but but the point is he walks
around with notes if donald trump had
walked around with note cards people
would have said
you know he has dementia or he has you
know whatever other cognitive things but
for some reason we don't talk about it
with joe biden and i don't know what
we're going to do about this because
it's a real problem well donald trump is
now back
given the rallies right he's out there
with the people and he asked the very
same question while on stage the other
day
in just five months the biden
administration has launched
an all-out assault on everything we
cherish
and we value under joe biden and the
left i don't know if it's joe to be
honest with you
it's somebody does anybody know who it
is
[Applause]
right like that's more true like who is
it does anyone know who it is
i don't think it's true uh joe like
that's more true than most of the
nonsense
we're getting out of joe or pasak or
anything else now i do want to just say
one other thing on this
which is that i would prefer
that even if i disagree with joe biden's
policies and i obviously do
right and i i think i have a pretty good
track record here i saw through the
nonsense i saw my
my good liberal friends whatever is left
of the
intellectual dark web crew or whatever
else it is the somewhat decent lefties
all saying don't worry dave
joe biden's going to stop the craziness
he'll stand up to the progressives
blah blah blah blah blah meanwhile he
actually was just a wolf
in sheep's clothing right like he just
has ushered in all of this
lefty lunacy printing money like crazy
exploding
budgets all of that stuff it was obvious
to me that he wasn't
going to be in charge and in some ways
that made him the most dangerous one
because if he would
if they had gone with someone like
bernie it would be like we all know it
it's like you're a socialist
you're an old grumpy socialist but we
know what it is we know how to fight it
biden it's much more confusing but i do
want to be clear about this which is
that
even if i disagree with joe biden's
policies which i obviously do
and i wish uh perhaps that he was more
of a moderate if such a thing exists
anymore
um as the president of the united states
you know he is
the guy operating right like he's the
doctor and we're all the patient
and he can do a lot of good and he can
do a lot of bad and i would prefer
that the guy that has the instrument as
they cut into our body and moves some of
the
organs around i would prefer that he has
a steady hand i would prefer that he has
the cognitive wherewithal
to make the right choices and know how
to operate and everything else
so when i say all this i can joke about
it in a way
but it's actually quite scary if you
think about it that this man is not in
charge
we don't know who is in charge and if he
is in charge if i'm wrong about all this
and he is in charge and there's
something wrong with him then we got an
even bigger problem
because he could put his finger on the
button anyway there will obviously be
be more about this but but for those of
you in the mainstream media
that are watching this show and i know
you guys do watch this show
if you're on cnn or msnbc or one of
these channels um
why don't you cover this a little bit
and it will and then
it will be more honest your approach
will be more honest you'd have to run
out there and say he has dementia you
don't have to run out there and say
there's
something deeply wrong with him or
something but you could say there's some
questions that should be asked right
like something doesn't seem right here
but instead what you do is by ignoring
it
and then the rest of us seeing the clips
online well then it
leads itself to a bunch of people not
believing any of the other garbage you
spew so in many ways you're kind of
doing my job for me but
it's like be a little bit better could
you be a little better than it would be
better for everybody
or is it just too late i suspect i know
the answer uh all right let's move on to
this critical race theory nonsense so
you know one of the things that's
happening over the last couple weeks is
that finally
because i think people like me and
people in these circles and people
online it's very similar actually to the
story that i just talked about with joe
biden
because the online people have been
exposing critical race theory
for its neo-racism for the systemic
racism which it wants to put into the
system
for the idea that white people in
essence are born guilty and are
guilty over the uh the sins
of their forefathers or actually not
even for their forefathers because no
one in my family owned
slaves so why would i be guilty of what
someone in my family did generations ago
i shouldn't be
and it didn't even happen so they want
you to be guilty by the color of your
skin
they've decided the critical race
theorists and the intersectionalists
the intersectionalityists and the
worksters they've decided
that things like being on time and
working hard
and empirical facts like two plus two
equals four that these are
uh tools of oppression and white
supremacy and everything else well one
of the things that's happened in the
last month is as this has been more and
more exposed by people online and chris
ruffo specifically who i'm going to get
to
in just a moment then suddenly the meme
went out
that no critical race theory doesn't
really exist
or it's not really what you're all
saying it is or it's just not really
being put into the institutions and it's
just sort of another right-wing
conspiracy theory sort of like joe biden
has cognitive problems
well actually we are seeing it infect
absolutely everything so chris ruffo uh
who you guys know who is a lawyer
he has done incredible work bringing
lawsuits into a bunch of different red
states of course it's red states to
fight critical race theory in schools in
that you wouldn't want children to be
taught neo-racism the same way you
wouldn't want
children to be taught nazism that it's
good you know what i mean you could
teach about nazis that's a very
different thing
but chris is doing a great job with this
he sent out this incredible tweet
and i'm going to he bulleted it out i'm
just going to read you some of it so
breaking
the nation's largest teachers union has
approved a plan to promote
critical race theory in all 50 states
and in 14 000 local school districts
the argument that critical race theory
isn't in k
k through 12 schools is officially dead
the union has also approved funding for
increasing the implementation of crt
in k-12 curricula and for attacking
conservative groups who oppose crt
indoctrination the teachers union has
made critical race theory its number one
priority
and want to implement it nationwide
according to a recent
yougov survey 58 of americans oppose
critical race theory including 72
percent of independents who believe
teaching it in schools is bad for
america
but the teachers union wants to double
down and impose this divisive ideology
on your children
the nea represents 3 million public
school employees in all 50 states
they have a 350 million dollar annual
budget
and an army of operatives in 14
000 local communities so we've got a
little more info on this but before i
get to that the key piece of this
is that what we've been hearing for the
last couple weeks is no
it's not really in schools no it doesn't
really exist well now we know
it does the gateway pundits got a little
bit more
laws banning the instruction of critical
race theory tenants in public schools
have passed in more than 20 states
and there is reason to hope that the
tide is beginning to turn in the fight
for the country's history and principles
unfortunately the zen education project
refuses to accept defeat
and desires to teach american children
that this country was founded upon the
dispossession
of native americans slavery structural
racism and oppression
as opposed to the principles of liberty
enshrined in the declaration of
independence and the constitution
now the zep is circulating a pledge to
teach the truth
which identifies left-wing methods of
analysis like critical race theory as
the truth
and decrees that the signees all of whom
are educators
refuse to be bullied into compliance
with the law so far according to the zen
education project
the pledge has been signed by more than
5 000 educators
in all 50 states and many of the signees
were more than happy to provide their
reasons
for signing so what is happening here in
effect
is that roughly these 20 red states that
are now passing these laws
to keep systemic racism
new school pernicious racism of the left
out of schools there are now groups
that are actually getting teachers to
basically say we will ignore the law
and we will teach the quote-unquote
truth
regardless this battle ain't going
anywhere and i saw an interesting back
and forth
uh between chris ruffo and james lindsay
who i've also had on the show many times
who's i think one of the the prime
um the prime purveyors of the truth when
it comes to critical race theory
uh in essence james lindsay was saying
that he's not hopeful that
uh despite the fact that he has now
spent the last few years of his life
fighting against critical race theory
in many ways more than almost anyone
that he's not very hopeful that this
thing is just coming and coming and
coming and it's going to get worse and
we're going to end up in some sort of
south africa situation roofo tweeted
back and said that he's
optimistic and and i responded and i
basically said
that i'm a world-weary optimist that's
the way i always describe myself i would
say i'm an optimist because how could i
talk about the news how could i talk
about the things i believe in
every day if i wasn't an optimist if i
didn't believe
that by me communicating these ideas to
you guys
that hopefully that gives you some of
the tools to take the right ideas to
your family and community and everything
else and then and then build a better
world that would make me an optimist
but i'm not just a blind eyed optimist
right i'm not just someone that thinks
just because we
say nice things or believe the right
thing or fight for the truth that
magically
these things um grow like i just don't
believe that so i would say i'm world
weary in that regard i'm a realist
and my argument to them in effect was
well look
as a world weary optimist i don't think
we can stop it
but i think we can actually basically
inoculate
the new the new converts right like the
new people who are about to be
brainwashed we can do something to save
them
but this thing's here these diversity
and inclusion
programs that are in so many of the
fortune 500 companies that are
most likely in the companies you work
for or the schools that you're sending
your kids to or whatever it might be
they're here those things are now
infected and cannot be saved i really
believe that
because even if they were to be saved
the damage that would happen
in in terms of saving them like how can
you have an organization
that believes that it's racist and was
going to hire based on skin color and
gender and all these things how can it
reverse that oh
sorry we got that wrong we're actually
going to start hiring based on skill and
passion
and you know education and the rest of
it you can't reverse it
so the only thing that we can do is
build new things and this is what i was
talking about on the show yesterday
in essence we we really need a parallel
economy and in some ways we need a
parallel country
that is not a call for america to split
up it is not a call for a civil war
but all of us that that don't believe
in this nonsense that don't believe in
this neo-racism that
that want to uh further
the the ideals that america was founded
on which are worthy ideals to continue
to push forward for for more equality
wherever equality doesn't exist
not equity equality i think we need to
build new things and that's why
when i started locals i made it very
clear to my entire team we will never
hire based on the color of skin we will
never hire based on your genitals
or on your gender or gender identity or
any of these ridiculous things and by
the way if you want to work for us
locals.com
jobs move down to miami and we're
looking for great people who are
actually hard working
and i don't care what uh skin color you
are i know that's called racist but
you know i'm old school what can i tell
you anyway this story isn't going
anywhere
we'll keep fighting it uh but speaking
of stories that aren't going anywhere
you know the trans stuff which
we end up having to spend so much time
talking about because it's it's so
i would say um nefarious in the way it's
put its tentacles into everything
so i'll give you the stupid disclaimer
just to start if you're trans
and you're an adult i don't care how you
live i don't care what you wear
i don't care who you marry i don't care
any of that stuff i don't care what
bathroom you go to blah blah blah
that being said i don't think young
children should transition
and chop off their genitals or do any
other things like that you can watch my
interview with abigail schreier if you
want
some more interview some more
information on that and i also think
that um you still have to go to if
you're going to jail you got to go to
the jail that's your biological jail
sort of like if you're playing sports
you got to play
with the people who are biologically the
same as you that's just how it is
uh thanks for the numbers here 0.6 uh
percent of u.s adults identify as
transgender so i really want you to
think
about how much time the transgender
argument
takes up when less than one percent
basically a half of one percent
of people identify as transgender that
isn't to say we should
treat those people poorly i don't want
laws against these people and i want
them
to find love and happiness and
fulfillment and purpose and all of those
things
but we shouldn't break the entire system
in honor of that well that seems to be
what we're doing
especially here in california we've got
some info from yahoo news
a california law allowing transgender
inmates to pick the prison gender of
their choice
has come under fire from a women's
rights group citing abuse of
females by men in a letter
to evil governor gavin newsom i added
evil the women's
liberation front accused the state of
violating the constitutional rights
of incarcerated women by allowing men
into their living quarters to prey on
women since the law took effect on
january 1st wlf
has received numerous complaints of
assaulted abused and traumatized women
at the hands of male inmates
transferred into their prisons wolf
legal director lauren
adams said so let's just be clear about
what's happening here
instead of sending people
to the prison that matches their
biological sex okay
we are now allowing men because this is
where it's happening it's not happening
with a lot of women
that transition to men to go into the
men's prison right that's not going to
end well we all know that wouldn't end
well
so what's happening is biological men
who either are trans or are perhaps
psychologically confused or are
pretending
i don't know we don't know these are
people are criminals and probably have a
series of other problems and
drug use and everything else but i'll
even i'm not even trying to make it
about that
let's just say you're a trans guy you're
a man
who's living as a woman okay that's just
fine but now we're going to put you in
women's prison and then what happens
violent assaults rapes all of these
things we know these things are
happening and again why isn't it
happening the other way where there
aren't women
who are trans men going into the men's
prison and beating the crap
out of men right like that's strange how
it never happens that way right there
aren't
an awful lot of girls who transition to
boys and then
crush all the boys in wrestling very odd
very odd
but this shouldn't surprise anybody
because
intersectionality has made everyone
stupid
it has made everyone absolutely stupid
and this is what wokism does to
everything
so during the election you may remember
this moment biden was speaking at some
big gay event
and just listen to what he said yes and
by the way in prison
in prison the determination should be
that
your sexual identity is defined by
what you say it is not what in fact the
prison says it is
really think how stupid and dangerous
and pandering
and nonsensical that is but that's let's
be clear
that was the man who was to become the
president of the united states who may
or may not actually be the one in charge
basically saying that what we're doing
here in california is the right thing to
do that you get arrested let's say you
i don't know let's just say you're a
serial rapist you know
serial rapist you raped a couple women
you know you put on a dress
and then you go and they're gonna
sentence you
and they say actually you know you've
got lifetime in jail because you're
raped maybe you killed a bunch of women
you know you did some bad stuff
and then you go oh well you know um it's
not
what's you know my biological sex it's
not what's on my
identification it's not because i have
the genitals of a man
i'm a woman and i want to go to the
women's prison well by joe biden
and by gavin newsom and the other
ridiculous people who run
the silly banana republic of california
we're going to send that guy
to a woman's prison you think we got a
problem here
and you see how these stories are
connected like this is directly
connected
to just destroying logic and reason
which is exactly what critical race
theory is so that's what
intersectionality is it's
linking together these opposed
depressions and within that link it then
will destroy
the teachers unions it will destroy our
prisons and by the way once you destroy
teachers unions
and then you just you know in effect
you're destroying our children's ability
to learn
and then you destroy the prisons our
ability to rehabilitate people
what what are you left with with the
society and none of that should surprise
you because i'll link it back to another
story we did yesterday which is how
the democrats were completely unable to
praise america on july 4th and we've got
people like
you know congresswoman corey bush and
congresswoman maxine waters and
congresswoman
aoc where they just basically couldn't
say anything good
about america on july 4. these people
don't think america is good so they
would gladly have
our schools go down and all our systems
go down and burn the whole thing down
so we have work to do allow me to take a
sip of
coffee
so as these things continue to crumble
in conjunction with each other
new york the state where i was born i
was born in brooklyn new york
in 1976 brooklyn when it was still cool
not brooklyn when it was you know
hipster uh
doofus brooklyn i was in brooklyn when
it was cool i grew up in long island i
went to suny binghamton state university
of new york
at binghamton one of the best state
schools in new york i lived in manhattan
for most of my adult life and then in
2013 i moved out to crazy california
so i am a true new yorker i love new
york city as i said in the intro
i i would spend weekends visiting my
grandparents and my great grandparents
in new york city my great-grandparents
had an amazing apartment
on central park west overlooking the
park my family
we really screwed up a real estate thing
didn't buy it when they passed away and
now it's long gone although who knows
what it's worth now and who would want
to live in new york city anyway but the
point is i love new york city like i
love
the upper west side i love the people
the subways the smells all the craziness
the pizza the bagels the whole thing
well new york city is now absolutely
crumbling and we should thank marxist
mayor
bill de blasio and of course we're gonna
have a new da who's gonna make it much
much worse
uh we've got some quotes here from the
new york post alvin bragg appears to
have won the democratic primary election
for manhattan district attorney
making him the presumptive new leader of
one of the most powerful prosecutor's
offices in the nation
amid surging violence in gotham
manhattanites should be hoping that
bragg takes crime seriously
although his biography is impressive his
proposals give reason to worry
digging further into his plans reveals
some truly radical proposals
first bragg will immediately begin
de-prosecuting certain offenses
refusing to punish violations of duly
enacted criminal laws
these include resisting arrest
trespassing fair evasion marijuana
possession
driving with a suspended license and any
traffic violation
for those offenses that are prosecuted
brag announced plans to allow just about
every offender
to walk free the same day michael can
you go back there so i can see all the
full list
of the things that he's going to
decriminalize so in essence what he's
doing as district attorney and by the
way this is what chessa beaudine
the ridiculous district attorney of san
francisco is doing
this is what george gascon our moronic
district attorney here in los angeles is
doing who was the d.a
in san francisco so they they spread
like cockroaches that's what these
people do we destroy one city
and then we move to another much like
the aliens in independence day right
they're not here to negotiate we're just
here to destroy you
so the some of the things that they will
not be arresting people
for resisting arrest that seems like a
problem if
you're doing something you're let's say
you're breaking into a store now you're
allowed to resist arrest meaning they're
not going to prosecute you for it so i
guess you'll get arrested
but then you're just going to be let off
trespassing oh so you can just
hop a fence go into anyone's house go
into anyone's
building that's okay fair evasion well
then why would anyone pay fair
this is what they do these things all
they think these things sound nice oh
we're just not gonna
you know get people in trouble for these
petty crimes well then really what
you're doing is you're punishing
law-abiding citizens
why should abiding citizens pay the 275
or whatever it is to swipe
your new york city subway card if you
can just hop the thing and no one's
going to do anything
marijuana possession well i'm not
totally clear what the
law is actually right now in new york
city related to buying marijuana maybe
we can get some info on that
um but again if it's illegal then you
can't do it right like we can have a
discussion about whether it should be
legal or not i'd be for legalizing
marijuana
but again you can't if you just if
you're just allowed to break certain
laws then we really don't have laws
driving with a suspended license okay
so you know sure you plowed your car
into a group of 20 people and got your
license suspended
do it again and for any traffic
violation well then why
stop at red lights right like everyone
will do whatever they want
uh oh here's some more information on
the marijuana situation this is new york
city
in new york city age 21 and over are
allowed to possess up to three
ounces of cannabis or
.85 ounces of concentrated cannabis
public smoking of cannabis is allowed
wherever cigarette smoking is
permissible
that's actually kind of funny because
the new york city cigarette smoking is
not permissible anywhere they actually
outlawed it even
downstairs outside buildings because
people would be
basically you know all the people from
these massive buildings in midtown
all the smokers would just be downstairs
smoking all day so everywhere you'd walk
in midtown would you just walk through a
giant
plume of smoke uh anyway if you don't
think that doing these things is
ridiculous and basically making crime
legal which is what these people are
doing and by the way i think chesa
beaudine in san francisco
and george gets gone here in la i think
they are both going to get recalled
and then they should actually have to
deal with the law
because i don't think and i would need
to speak to a legal expert on this but i
i've heard enough about this
that as a da you're supposed to do what
the law dictates right you don't get to
decide really this is
this is a trick that the progressives
have done that we can oh we can bring in
a district attorney who can just decide
when
and if we're going to prosecute crimes
so i think these guys could be in legal
trouble themselves you know we have
laws laws exist and if laws are to exist
and we're a nation of laws
and there is right and there is wrong
and there's legal and illegal
well then we have to enforce those
things so these guys could be in a lot
of trouble
but if you don't think that these
policies are making things worse well i
can show you
roughly a hundred thousand videos of
awful things happening in san francisco
this one's from this morning and you
really got to watch this whole thing
this is a clown car of robbers
breaking into neiman marcus
look [ __ ]
[Music]
freaking white supremacists it just
never stops with these people
now think about that neiman marcus have
you ever been to neiman marcus it's an
upscale
uh shopping center okay it's an upscale
department store
it's sort of like a nordstrom or a
bloomingdale's they've got
expensive stuff there you're not allowed
to just walk into a store and take stuff
i was actually at nordstrom last week i
thought i was going to get some new
sneakers for my birthday party didn't
see anything i liked
but had i seen one that i liked i
wouldn't have been allowed or i
shouldn't have been allowed i should say
to just walk up to the sneaker take it
and run out of the store
but in essence when you have district
attorneys that say we will not prosecute
these things
these petty thefts you know thefts under
800.
well then in essence you're saying to
these people to these kids
these misguided kids go ahead
do whatever you want and then what you
will watch
is a city collapse and san francisco is
collapsing by the way
according to the washington examiner
just this morning almost
half of san francisco residents are
planning on moving out of the city
due to rising crime really think about
that
half the people in what was one of the
great cities
of america i mean san francisco you know
i joke about it all the time but the
first time i was in san francisco about
10 years ago
it was the first time i had ever gone to
another city and thought boy i could
really live
in this city i thought the people were
great i thought the food was great the
geography was kind of cool the full
house house was there
i was into it it's an abject
disaster the last time i was the last
i'll tell you the last two times i was
in san francisco
a couple years back i was in san
francisco i had done an event uh with
candace owens and we went out to eat
to um morton's steakhouse which i don't
know what street it's on in san
francisco you guys could google it but
like a perfectly nice
street and morton's is a you know a
well-known established steak joint like
we weren't we weren't you know in the
downtown
and skid row and our car got broken into
while it was parked right outside the
restaurant and i took a picture some of
you i'm sure saw this on social media i
took a picture and video
of the broken glass everywhere and our
car broken into and they had stole my
bag and it had my
notebooks and i think my ipad was in
there and a bunch of other stuff
and i posted the picture in the video
and i got literally
thousands of responses on tw on twitter
basically people saying what kind of
idiot leaves a bag in their car in san
francisco
and then i did some googling after and
it is a fact the amount of break-ins
just people just literally
just throw a rock through a window or
they punch through a window whatever it
is
of a car they steal the stuff people
don't park on the streets in san
francisco
anymore okay so that's what's going on
in san francisco and then the last time
i was in san francisco
was like two days before lockdown uh so
that was you know
about a year and a half ago at this
point and uh we were in san francisco
because we were raising funds for locals
and i was going all the vc things and it
was a very weird time because people
were freaking out and the masks were
just starting at gloves
and also the economy was tanking it was
it was literally the day
that the uh that the economy tanked that
the market just crashed and we still
were able to actually raise a little
money it was
it was pretty wild but i
saw several people shooting up drugs on
the street the amount of homeless
encampments everywhere i mean it's
craziness
so if you think that deregulating crime
is is good go to those cities move to
those cities see what's happening
and it's the same thing when when you
see not only deregulating crime
we know what's happening in terms of
murder in all these cities murder is a
crime by the way
but that's related to gun laws right
like you think oh
we're going to have the strictest gun
laws and then people will stop shooting
people
91 was it 91 91 people if i'm not
mistaken were shot
in chicago this past weekend i think
eight were killed those were the last
numbers
that i had but don't tell that to
chicago mayor lori lightfoot because
she'll just call you a racist
anyway guys we got work to do i'm in the
mood to do some work are you
join me 100 shot 18 fatally sorry i
under that my 91 shot
and what i say eight dead no it was a
hundred people were shot in chicago this
past weekend
18 fatally happy fourth of july to
people in chicago i mean absolutely
unbelievable
uh guys my interview with jd vance is
coming out
tomorrow we're doing that this afternoon
so part one will be up tomorrow
and i'm talking to people and
interacting with people
and i'm doing it bot and troll free all
day long over at reubenreport.locals.com
hope to see you there
and you can get all our videos ad free
and now we've got live streaming there
and a whole bunch of other stuff
anyway have a great day everybody we'll
do it again tomorrow see ya